We and many other creatures share a mechanism for
what you might call extracting numerosity or the number of things from the
environment.
It's really very important for all sorts of creatures and for all sorts of
reasons.
Extracting numerosity from the environment. What does that mean?
What I mean by this is that our fish needs to know how many other Fisher in a
shell. So it enjoined the larger show.
So the numerosity efficient shells is important.
Lions need to know how many invading lions into their territory.
There are usually this is done through sound.
They can hear them coming so they can decide whether to flee or to fight.
So this is just extracting the number of things from the environment,
because they have to decide what's relevant in the environment.
So the lions are at paying attention to the number of roars that they can hear.
And the number of distinct roars, the fish are paying attention,
not to the seaweed, but just to other fishes are spending around.
So they have to focus on a particular set of objects.
So this is a mechanism that fish and lions, and we share these.
We think we share them. We certainly have similar mechanisms,
whether all these mechanisms come from a common ancestor or not. I don't know.
And this requires genetic research at the moment. That's not available.
Professor,
do animals need to know the number or do they just need to know a greater than
or equal sort of thing? Do they know, okay,
there's more on the left than the right.
They don't need to extract an actual number, right?
Sometimes that's enough having a, you know,
a rough sense of how many there are may be sufficient because if you've got a
lot of fish swimming around in a shell that say a hundred fish over here versus
50 fish over there, you're not going to be able to enumerate them,
but you've got to have a way of extracting at least approximate numerosity from
that, the way in which that stand is probably something like this.
You kind of extract the approximate density of the fish.
Then you see how big an area these fish cover say you could,
it's basically density times area than fish. Fish can do that.
Sometimes you need to do it. Exactly.
So if there are three lions defending against four lions,
they need to know that there's just one more of them.
Then they have a decision to make we're four on there three. Then we attack,
we defend our territory. So sometimes you need to know exactly.
Sometimes approximate we'll do.
One proposal came up in the early eighties is that we all possess an
accumulator. And so the more things that you experience the fuller,
the accumulator gets, let me give you a helpful analogy. Supposedly,
I've got a jug that say with marks on it.
And for each thing I see I have a cup of water and I pour it into the junk.
So for each thing, however big,
the thing is it's the same cup of water or whatever the thing is,
it's the same cup of water. So if I see three things,
then the joke will be filled to there by see four things there'll be to there,
five things they're up to about 10 things. This is a very simple mechanism.
There's evidence. Now, at least in frogs,
that there's a particular neuron that does this in monkeys.
There's evidence that there's a mechan,
a single neurons that seem to behave like one of these accumulators.
That is the more things that the monkey sees, the more,
this particular neuron fires. So there's, I know this is number five.
So I can say this a monotonic relationship between the number and the firing
rate in the case of other animals, it may not be firing rate.
It might be done in some other way. And we don't know, uh,
it may be done within a neuron or it may be done in terms of connections between
neurons. Now give you an example from frogs. Now,
most people think frogs are pretty stupid, but here, um,
they perhaps tell us human something that we ought to have known all along.
So imagine these particular species of frogs that have been started,
they're in a swamp and they want to mate and the male wants to mate with a
female. So it has to attract a female, the female can't see it.
And he can't see the female. So it's meeting is done by, uh, by sound.
So what the male frog has to do is at least not the meeting itself,
not the net, that's true, not the meeting itself, but the choice of a mate, uh,
depends on sound. What the male has to do.
It has to make it appear that it is the most,
the fittest male in the swamp.
And it does this by making a series of noises called chucks.
I'm I'm up. Well, okay. I've got really good at
The female will be attracted by the number of chucks in a
phrase. Cause the more chunks you can make more fit,
more substantial. You are now numbers important.
It's better than volume because volume will depend upon how far away you are
from the male. But number doesn't depend on how far away you are from the male.
And it turns out that frogs compete with each other.
So if I make five chops,
my neighboring man.
Might make five. Plus a woman.
This might escalate until you reach the limit of how much breath you can
have to make a number of chunks in the phrase. Second auction that it is,
it's a bit like an auction. Now why this,
I don't know if it applies to humans that if you make a lot of noise or war
noises, you're more likely to attract a mate. But anyway,
that's the way it works in fog. Now what's interesting is,
but Gary Rose at the university of Utah,
he showed that there's a neuron in the brain of the frog.
That seems to act like an accumulator. Uh, so it,
it heres the number of chunks made by, uh,
another frog and it thinks aloe he's made five.
I have to make an extra one.
So then it will generate an extra Chuck to make it six
chucks. So it's not counting the number.
That the other guy made. It has to count how many it makes.
Try. It has. Yeah. I've only been making false. I better, I better up my game.
So it looks as though there's, there is, uh,
something rather like an accumulates in the brain of the frog.
Now we don't know much about it for other the brains of other creatures.
And we don't know whether there's an equivalent mechanism in our brain,
but there's no reason why there shouldn't be. So for example,
when we think about timing, there's a gene, which you can find in the fruit fly,
which were already very, very distantly related to called Tim,
which is a timing gene, which responds to a particular interval.
Now it turns out this Tim gene is conserved in us.
Now we use it in a rather different way from the, the fruit fly.
And it combines with other genes and other mechanisms to make our timing
mechanism more general, uh, and more detailed than the fruit fly. But,
you know, if there's, uh, a gene in the fruit fly for time,
there could be a gene in the frog, or even in insects.
It can also count for counting,
which we share with them and which builds an equivalent type of mechanism.
You used the analogy of like a measuring cylinder or a vessel being filled in
an actual brain.
What is being filled like where is where's this stuff being stored,
what's being filled up to accumulate into.
I can imagine the pulses from the neurons, but how are they stored?
Yes, that's, that's a very, very good question.
And it's one that is extremely controversial. You've hit on a very raw,
what should I say, nerve, um, here.
So one argument which has been made by Randy Gulistan at Rutgers
university, and he was also, uh,
thought he was one of the co-organizers of this meeting.
He argues that things like time and number are actually stored in
polynucleotides in, in the neuron itself.
And this is going to have an effect on the way in which the neuron connects with
other neurons.
Another idea is that it's got to do with the connections between neurons.
There've been some modeling exercises, usually neural networks,
where either the network learns to recognize a particular numerosity like
five newness, because if it's five NUS,
it goes into a particular state and the virtual neurons connect up in a
particular way. And if it's not five, then they connect up in a different way.
Or it can just be some kind of internal mechanism, which for example,
to harness proposed,
whereby a network of neurons can organize itself into
say Tunis or threeness or fullness or five five-plus roughly speaking.
So does that mean as each accumulation happens, then your network says, okay,
let's move into foreigners position,
or there's been another one that's moving to five and a specific, Oh,
now we're going to go into six in this position. Yeah.
That's, that's what the neural network people would say.
And it's not entirely clear how that's going to work.
That's one of the current controversies,
but in a simple accumulator mechanism,
it will be a single that responds to a
particular numerosity of whatever it happens to be tuned to. If it's,
let's say tuned to the number of sounds,
it hears that's what it will respond to.
So it'll respond more to fineness than to foreigners. And in fact,
there is some evidence that in monkey cortex and indeed in
kind of homologous part of bird brain,
there are individual neurons that responds preferentially
to particular numerosity. So if the monkey sees an array of five,
this neuron will respond more to five than to foreigners or to sixes.
And similarly in the bird brain,
there is evidence for single neurons acting as an accumulator. In fact,
in the monkey brain,
the number of neurons seem to be in a cleft in the parietal lobe.
So the parietal lobes run there and there's a kind of a fold at the bottom of
the fold. Technically the funders, there are these number neurons.
If the number of neurons are down there on the lateral surface, here,
there are going to be accumulator neurons, sometimes called summation neurons,
which fire more when they experience more things.
And it's believed that it's not been yet demonstrated that there's a connection
between these neurons, these accumulated neurons and the number of neurons.
So if this accumulator neuron gets to five minus,
then it will activate down here the neuron,
which preferentially responds to five NUS.
So that's the way people think it works at the moment.
If we've seen this accumulator, perhaps working in the frog,
which is very exciting,
why haven't we been able to see it in humans that we probably study even more
than frogs? Why has it not shown itself yet? Well.
That's an interesting question then.
And that's because we can use very fine
electrodes to probe the brains of frogs. And at the moment,
we're not allowed to do that with humans, unless, for example,
it's in the course of surgery. So for example,
in intractable epilepsy,
the surgeon would like to remove the epileptic focus,
but the surgeon would like to do that without damaging the parts of the brain
that the patient really needs.
So you have to find out which bits of the brain are really important to the
patient.
And what you do is you open up the skull and you put a grid of electrodes on the
exposed brain. And then you see with various tests,
which parts of the brain rather selectively.
Now just a few thousand neurons respond,
let's say to speech or to particular words or this case to particular
numbers.
And so what for example is a Parviz in Stanford has done is he's
found neurons or perhaps neuron clusters that respond to particular
digits. So in part of the brain down there, um, which,
where you do some of your visual processing,
there seem to be little clusters of neurons that respond to the digit five.
They're not to five minus, okay. Not to the numerosity vibe and other,
some other work done by Carlos.
And Menza in iZone at the university of part of her.
And what he does is something slightly different with epileptic patients.
What he does is he stimulates the brain in such a way that it
temporarily disables, the bit that's being stimulated.
So he's been looking at calculation.
So there are particular bits of the brain, which if you stimulate them stops,
you doing addition, but not multiplication.
And another bit that stops you doing multiplication, but not addition.
So it looks as though,
although addition and multiplication is spread over several different sites,
each particular site,
just a few thousand neurons is doing a particular arithmetical
operation.
These people have to be conscious for, for them to know, yeah.
They have to be conscious that's right. So we open up the, well,
not me personally,
but the brain is opened up and the person has to be conscious or,
or else that the surgeon doesn't know what the different bits of the brain are
doing.
With the people that really want to know this,
the inner workings of how our brains dealing with numbers.
One of the problems is that, uh,
not everybody is very good at learning arithmetic and that many different
branches of mathematics. And, uh,
some people are not very good at arithmetic, but a very good at geometry.
We've tested some of those. Some people are not really good at geometry,
and we're very good at arithmetic and we've tested some of those.
So I'm talking really here about arithmetic,
cause this is the closest we get to what animals can do.
So there are some people who,
despite every opportunity don't seem to be able to develop arithmetic
in the normal way. Now,
if they've inherited a mechanism for rep
extracting numerosity from the environment, sorry,
if I have to use that expression again and then representing it in their,
in their mind, if that's not working very well, uh,
then this is a problem because this seems to be the foundation for learning,
arithmetic, understanding what the numerosity of a set is,
is critical to learning arithmetic. A set has a definite number of members.
If you add another member, it changes the numerosity. If you take a member away,
it changes the numerosity. It's very exact, very specific.
And it's the difference between a set of five and a set of six,
which has just got one more member.
So if you're not very good at representing sets,
and then numerosity is both of which, by the way, abstract things, I mean,
the set is abstract.
And the numerosity of the set property in the set also have track.
That's a whole other issue.
That's played philosophers for at least two and a half millennia.
The point here is that these people are not very good at the
foundations, not very efficient at the foundations for arithmetic.
So they don't, for example, know that five nurses,
just one more than foreigners, they can count. Okay.
But that internal representations not very good. We, we might speculate have,
uh, they're accumulated doesn't work very efficiently.
So if it doesn't work very efficiently, they're not very,
they don't have a very reliable representation. Let's say of five minus.
Uh,
and that means that the relationship between their representation of five nurses
and the digit five or the word five is not very good.
And this means that they are really bad at learning arithmetic.
They need extra help rather than the way that a dyslexic who has a problem
relating lesser strings to words has a problem that needs special
help.
What we've been trying to do is trying to create digital environments in
which kids can play around with sets combined sets together,
which is like addition or separate sets,
just like subtraction and relate sets two digits. And two words.
We feel this might help overcome this problem,
which is usually called dyscalculia.
Dyscalculia is actually quite a big problem. I mean,
it probably affects something like 5% of the population.
And it's been calculated that this costs us at least two and a half billion
pounds a year in the UK. So worldwide,
if it's 5% of the worldwide population, it's a serious and expensive business,
uh, because people who've got dyscalculia have all sorts of consequential life
problems. Like they're not very good with money. They're not very good at,
at work. So it's known to be a serious problem in everyday life.
One of the first dyscalculia books we ever saw was in prison for shoplifting.
And the reason he shoplifted it was,
he was too embarrassed to go to the counter with his purchases because he didn't
know how much money to give.
And he didn't know if he was getting the right chain. And of course,
kids in school, you know, the 5% of kids in school who have this problem,
get this every well, five days a week because they have, uh, um,
maths lessons five days a week.
So one of the things we're trying to do is to help these kids overcome that
problem for which you need specialized help. Now,
one of the things I'm trying to persuade teachers,
educational professionals like educational psychologists,
and ultimately the government is that the problem with these discount Kuliks is
that this mechanism that we've seen operating in a whole range of different
creatures might be the same in humans.
That Johnny is not really as good as Billy or on these kinds of tasks.
We're trying to show that this is an innate problem. Rather like colorblindness,
a small mutation has affected the way in which this accumulated mechanism in the
brain has been built. And this is, this has got long long-term consequences.
Unfortunately, the government doesn't recognize it at the moment and, um,
other, uh, bodies that should be taking it seriously. Um,
and not recognizing it either. However, uh,
Singapore,
which is a country that always comes top or close to the top on all
international mathematical comparisons, they take it seriously. They say,
we've got 10% of kids who need learning support in mathematics.
We don't know why they're having this problem,
but we'd like to try and help them.
At least maybe half of those will be dyscalculia X.
So where we're collaborating with the Singapore government and the national
Institute of education there to try and develop some digital environments in the
first place to help these kids ever come their problems.
Dyslexia doesn't have this problem of recognition that help does it. No,
it doesn't. One of the reasons.
It's thought that if you can't,
if you'll find any reading difficult or spelling difficult,
this is a real handicap and it is a real handicap.
Also a lot of celebrities have come out as dyslexic,
uh, showing that it's possible to be successful, even though you're dyslexic.
However, it's also the case that if you having, if you've got poor literacy,
you also got worse life chances,
but it also turns out, well, if you've got poor numeracy,
you've got even worse life chances than having poor literacy,
but why isn't that coming out? Because people think, Oh, well, it's,
it's okay to say I'm terrible at math. Um,
but it's not okay to say I'm terrible at language,
or I'm terrible at reading or I'm terrible at spelling. Well,
sometimes you say that. Um, so I think attitudes are a bit different. Also.
The other thing is that vastly more money has been thrown at the
dyslexia problem than, uh, has been thrown at the dyscalculia,
probably vastly more money, uh, both here in America and Europe. But of course,
this is part of what I call the virtuous or the vicious triangle,
because there's no recognition, there's no money because there's no money.
There's no research because there's no research,
there's no recognition and so on.
Whereas if we could just intervene in one of those nodes in the triangle,
maybe we could make a big difference.
If you've got better research or more research or more spectacular research,
we get more recognition.
You get parents who are complaining to their local MP
that their children are not getting the right type of help because they're just
Qlick then government might change their mind. But even though there's a,
the British dyslexia association and there was dyslexia action.
And then of course, there's all autistic society as ADHD societies.
There isn't a dyscalculia association,
the British dyscalculia association.
So parents at least bear some of the responsibility here,
but of course they don't know that the reason that that Johnny is not
learning arithmetic is because he's just calculated.
They think either thing that Johnny is lazy or Johnny is stupid,
but in fact he's not, he's just disco kill it.
Okay. So this is a digital environment that we've created to help dyscalculia X.
And the idea is that they understand, uh,
about the relationship between digits and sets and they understand
about what sets or like.